in goes a for and we're going to go
ahead and continue down with our King
give a better position for King and the
c5 square is actually the outpost for
our King for a while he is going to kind
of hang out there and our minor pieces
the bishop at night are going to be
doing most of the work for for the short
while so we're going to go ahead and see
where the King goes the king is going to
try to make a fast track to the h1
square and we're going to do what we did
before and that's activate our Knight
and try to take away some squares and
we're going to go to b4 and it's done
for two reasons
with the knight here we're taking away
two light squares which is the c2 and
the d4 now the dark squares as you're
going to see in just a moment are going
to be taken away from from the bishop
when we bring the bishop and activate
him the King can't come to the c-4
square because of the king he can't come
to this d4 square and so he's eventually
going to have to make his way on dark
squares and so our next move is going to
be to activate the bishop and make sure
that he does not do this but at the time
being we've blocked off the light square
so he cannot get past these and for just
a little while we're going to actually
leave our Knight there so that he can't
do this we're going to see where black
goes and black comes down to b2 and
black now wants to try to move along
these dark squares so his next moves
wants to be c2 so we're actually going
to stop c2 a lot of people get the
mistake and try to come down to e5 and
check the king but again when I try to
check the game or try and check make the
cane so we're going to come here to f4
and block off these two dark squares and
the night as we talked about blocks out
these light squares
and so black is not able to retreat to
the h1 square so black in this situation
is probably and try to make a move back
to the a1 square since we have this
blocked off well it looks like he's
first going to move to the h1 square so
we're actually going to kind of just
improve our position with our bishop our
knight is nicely placed he's still
defending these light squares and the
black King still can't come past this
wall that we've created so we're just
going to bring the bishop a little bit
closer and you can already see the wall
we've created that black King cannot
come against the bishop has all of these
dark squares covered the King has this
square and the knight has the two light
squares so the black king is has to
retreat now and he retreats and we're
actually going to improve our Bishop one
more and just from the subtle move we've
created another wall that the black King
cannot come to again the bishop has the
dark squares the knight has this light
square and the King has this light
square as well so the King's going to
have to do something he's probably going
to now retreat to the a1 square and he
does he moves to a4 and now we want to
make sure that he can't come back to
this a5 square and so we want to make
sure that our bishop is aligned there so
we're going to go ahead and move our
knight to see excuse me see to activate
him a better position and allow for our
bishop to block off these two dark
squares so the black King can no longer
come to the eight squared and he's going
to have to come back to this area
and he's going to come attacker night so
we know for sure we have to move or not
we want to make sure that we put them in
the best position and black obviously
would like to either take the night or
take this position from the night and go
along these light squares so we want to
move the night where he is out of the
way of harm and at the same time
blocking this light squared so we're
going to actually move our night to D
for taking away this light square and
these dark squares are taken by the
bishop and this light square is taken by
the king so we have another wall that
the black King cannot go around so the
black King is going to try to retreat
again and now we are going to get the
King involved and we're actually just
going to get our King and push the king
the black King all the way down the line
as you've seen we already have a line on
this C file the black King cannot come
past this C file because of our minor
pieces and so we're just going ahead and
get our King involved so King to b6 and
black starts to retreat and we move our
King into position you can see the wall
we've created of moves that he cannot
make and the black King is going to come
down our black our excuse me our King is
going to continue his track down to the
a1 square and we have a wall created of
moves that the black King cannot make
and the black King is going to go closer
and now we can actually activate our
bishop and get him into the game a
little bit better close the King in so
we're going to go ahead and move our
bishop to c1 now the black King can move
to a 1 or b1 it doesn't matter our next
move will be the same and that's just
going to be Bishop to a3 and the bishop
is blocking off these two dark squares
and the knight is blocking off this C 2
square so the black King cannot come to
this H 1 square he's going to have to
retreat
and it doesn't matter which one he goes
to we're going to go ahead and bring our
if he comes to a two we can move our
night first but if he comes to a one we
can move our King first so just keep
that in mind so we're first going to go
ahead and activate our King here and
black only has one move to b1 and then
we're going to head and put our knight
in a better position at e2 again the
black king can't come to c1 because of
the bishop and the knight now so his
only move is a1 and now we can finish
off the King we can check in with B to
check and after he moves we can move our
knight and swoop in for the checkmate so
hope this helped I hope conceptually you
have a better feel for how to checkmate
with the bishop in Knight
it's a very fun in game once you
understand it if you want some practice
on my website the chess website comm you
can go and under in games you can
practice under key Knight but definitely
going to be having a lot more videos so
please subscribe hope everyone enjoy
leave comments or questions for me and
hope y'all enjoy Thanks